[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what is making those headlines with
selma shah broadcaster and political
commentator and polly mckenzie director
of the demos think tank both with us
from now until just before midnight so
welcome to both of you as ever let's
take a look first of all at those front
pages starting with the metro
shot in the back that is the headline
which leads on what it calls clear
evidence of russian war crimes in
ukraine the shooting of unarmed
civilians caught on camera
the growing row over the northern
ireland protocol leads the telegraph
which quotes the former brexit minister
lord frost as saying boris johnson
should rip up the deal with the same
toughness that he's shown over ukraine
the eye meanwhile says the house of
lords is trying to stop the deal being
scrapped
and the guardian says that the u.s is so
concerned that it's sending a team of
influential congressmen to the uk
to try to intervene
the daily mail reports that ross johnson
has ordered a massive cut in the civil
service to free up money for tax cuts
and with more fines issued over
pottygate the mirror says downing street
is now the home of the uk's worst
covered lawbreakers
the financial times has news of problems
with the cryptocurrency market after an
important stabilizing part of the
trading chain known as tether lost its
link to the us dollar and tumbled in
value while the sun reports that its
writer deborah james is to be made a
dame in recognition of her high profile
fight against cancer she is currently
receiving end of life care
well just a quick reminder that by
scanning the qr code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out those front pages while you watch
the program so let's uh bring in our
guest name um lester now salman shah and
paulie mckenzie welcome to both of you
um so perhaps not surprising given what
we saw in brussels today uh the issue
over the border in the rhc making many a
front page um where are we at then um
daily telegraph uh quotes lord frost but
um polly you take us through this one
so lord frost um
is very keen for the prime minister to
basically suspend the protocol that
would require legislation which liz
trust has talked about didn't quite make
it into the queen's speech and he has
given a speech in the united states
at the right-wing heritage foundation
basically making this case and also
intriguingly telling joe biden the
president of the united states to stop
lecturing us which is an odd thing to
say in a lecture in someone else's
country about the president of that
country but nevertheless we are where we
are
um what's you know just astonishing
about this even though again we're stuck
in this nightmarish situation is that
this is the deal which people voted for
under the banner of get brexit done they
said this was an oven-ready deal they
said it was perfect boris johnson said
there would be no checks in the irish
sea and now they're complaining that the
deal that they signed and celebrated has
this problem in it everybody told them
there was a problem nevertheless
um
you know we are in a really difficult
situation because following the northern
ireland uh assembly elections there
isn't cross-community support
for the protocol the dup are refusing to
go into a power-sharing arrangement with
sinn fein who who topped the poll
partly because of the protocol because
the problem is there isn't
cross-community consent for suspending
the protocol either another fact that
lord frost unfortunately seems to gloss
over
yes the uh the telegraph uh saying the
protocol was agreed to stop the need for
goods checks at the land border
critically for the good fight agreement
as you said between ulster and the
republic but the level of red tape
demanded by the eu on shipments arriving
in northern ireland from great britain
has spoke to unionists feels like
separation does it not from from great
britain um hillary ben made an
interesting intervention um in brussels
today um to maharish uh shefkovich the
uh the lead negotiator on this saying
you you wave the rules on medicines
which was really critical why can't you
do it for example for things arriving in
supermarkets in northern ireland that
are not intended to go anywhere else so
where does the fault lie in this and how
dangerous is it if the uk starts to
threaten to pull parts of this deal
i think the thing we've got to remember
in this circumstance is that the
triggering of article 16 is a process
that we have to go through and the eye
obviously is talking about that process
and how that process can be
um you know scrutinized by parliament
and certainly uh
certain lordships are making it clear
that they wouldn't just uh allow this
legislation to go through unamended or
easily if that is what the government
decides to do
so we have the rhetoric that is coming
from people like lord frost and on the
front page of the telegraph that is all
about ripping up a deal but in reality
this is something that exists within the
conditions of the protocol that requires
article 16 that can be triggered
unilaterally and for it to require
legislation and further discussion so
even if you start that process actually
it's going to take quite a while for for
you to uh be able to go through it and
work out some kind of accommodation that
helps i
do think that you know
the difficulty here for the government
is exactly as polly
highlighted that
it is something that we did sign up to
although i go back to my original point
that you know the triggering of article
16 is there for a reason because if it
doesn't work it also
endangers the good friday agreement
because we do not have um an executive
in northern ireland at the moment and
we've had we've been in this situation
before and the ultimate outcome is not
going to be good for the northern irish
people if we sort of descend into this
rhetoric war with the eu
yes and obviously this brought into
sharp focus by those national assembly
elections last week but for all those
people at home thinking oh my goodness
it's years since brexit you know surely
this is all done and dusted can't we
just get rid of it and why are you still
talking about it we turn to the guardian
which suggests that a u.s team is flying
in
because they're so worried about it we
know that joe biden is absolutely
committed to the good friday agreement
and the us says his role as a guarantor
suggestions that any trade deal between
the uk and america would be flummoxed by
this but polly remind us why this is why
this is so important the integrity of
the the uk
unionists would say is at stake here
well it is you know we have established
because we have left the european union
and we've made it really clear we want
to have different rules about imports
and exports than the european union
that perfectly reasonable except for the
fact that if you want to have different
rules for the imports and exports
between the united kingdom and the
european union then the european union
needs a border between us
and it
the problem is nobody wants to have a
real physical land border between
northern ireland and the rest of the
island of ireland because part of the
good friday agreement is that there
shouldn't be checks there
and so therefore in order to protect the
territorial integrity of the european
union the agreement was that we would
instead put the checks in the irish sea
and you know of course it's incredibly
frustrating to be not be able to send
goods from one part of the united
kingdom to another part of the united
kingdom but if you do if you have
complete freedom
how precisely is the european union
supposed to
ensure that goods we've decided to let
in from brazil or the united states or
wherever it might be that they don't
want
literally what is the plan without
checks between northern ireland and
ireland to stop them going in and it's
reasonable for us to say that the checks
in the rsc are very difficult but we
thus far have come up with nothing
really to actually meet what the
european union is asking for which is
just as reasonable if you know they are
allowed to have important export checks
as determined by their own rules
well let's just have a look at the eye
salmon you've already mentioned it
obviously but um it suggests that the
foreign secretary's plans to scrap parts
of the northern ireland protocol could
be delayed by up to a year what if we
can see the eye again
with peers believed to be ready to
obstruct the necessary legislation so
we'll see what happens with that but i'm
going to move on if you don't mind to
the daily mail with the suggestion um
that up to a fifth of civil servants his
jobs could go 91 000 the daily mail
tells us which would save about 3.5
billion pounds a year freeing up
resources to help ease the cost of
living through
question mark tax cuts possibly now
selma do they always go towards chopping
civil service jobs as a way to to free
up money and is it viable to to do that
do you think
so polly and i will both recall we both
served in the coalition government when
there was a big contraction in the size
of the civil service and i think the way
that this is being presented in the mail
uh is is sort of it speaks to a headline
and it speaks to you know this uh idea
that okay or we'll if we cut out the
civil service by cutting out some kind
of management fact in reality that's not
really how government works and if you
are embarking on some kind of as the
government says it is an ambitious
program of delivery
taking away those people that actually
deliver is counterproductive to that aim
and you know also the definition of
civil servant you know people who work
at the border people who work in
agencies like the passport agency or the
dvla or anything of that sort are also
civil servants so where are these cuts
actually going to happen that's going to
deliver 3.5 billion and that's a
one-time cut this is not something
that's going to appear on the balance
sheet every year
and those kinds of cuts cost as well
because there's redundancy payments
there's a loss of institutional
knowledge it's all that kind of thing
that that comes as a as a result of it
so
you know whilst the headline might seem
like it's uh progressive in terms of
making savings and cost cutting actually
an administration like the government
doesn't function in exactly the same way
as a business would yeah that's
interesting mr johnson told the daily
mail we've got to cut the cost of
government to reduce the cost of living
he said the civil service had become
swollen during the pandemic and more
than 90 000 jobs had to go and of course
um a sort of banging heads together
session you might call it with this a
cabinet away day today uh in stoke on
trent uh trying to bring to life the
queen speech we're told but no doubt
they're also talking about these
inventive ideas to try to sort cost of
living polly what do you reckon
i'm afraid i um approach this story with
deep cynicism
um
perhaps there are efficiencies in the
civil service of course there are but
the idea that he's so the prime minister
has given departments a month to come up
with a plan and it's written as if boom
91 000 jobs will be gone three and a
half billion saved and it'll be back in
your pocket by sundown that's absolute
nonsense it takes years and years to
make these reductions osama says during
the coalition years from 2010 to 2015 we
achieved a really sizable reduction in
the number of civil servants that has
ballooned we've mentioned the pandemic
but also because i'm afraid to save
brexit we decided to repatriate to take
back control of a whole bunch of policy
areas including our borders
agricultural policy
we needed to hire a whole bunch of new
civil servants to do work that europeans
used to do now
again that's a reasonable choice but it
does require people to do the work and
you then have the pandemic and a massive
expansion of public health controls
again quite understandable so
this idea that suddenly this is going to
put money back in your pockets nonsense
the reality is if the government wanted
to put money into people's pockets they
could do so they could increase money in
the benefit system to reach those who
are struggling with heating and eating
within their own fiscal targets if they
want to help with the cost of living
they can do so they don't need to make
these cuts if the cuts are a good idea
they will take time years in fact to
implement watching the press preview
with me once again sal michael
broadcaster and political commentator
and polly mckenzie director of the demos
think tank welcome back to both of you
uh so let's go to our next story then
which is uh i suppose would have it
would have hit bigger should certain
people have been involved in this salmon
what do you reckon uh more fines
considerably more fines it has to be
said for those who partied in downey
street
yes so the met have issued 50 more fines
to uh party goers who attended and
organized a christmas party on whatsapp
i think this is the famous one with the
cheese and wine um and
amazingly um the prime minister and uh
other senior people in number 10 have
not been issued with fines but what's
very interesting in this story is that
um that old character dominic cummings
has come back up and he's been tweeting
about the fact that actually uh they had
been told that the party was within
kovid rules i don't know who told them
and why they couldn't make a judgment
themselves but um it was within the
rules and accusing the prime minister of
throwing junior people under a bus uh
and sort of saying that this would bode
very badly for a coven inquiry that's
that's coming uh so lots of the original
drama from all of this to unpack in the
story but as you say
something that was such a huge political
story a master of weeks ago has now
slightly dissipated and is not not even
on the front pages
just a minute and a half uh left so
let's just reflect on the sun front page
which i think many people would agree is
a a really good use of the honor system
for the extraordinary woman who is
deborah james
yeah an incredible woman who's now been
made a dame in honor of the um
the campaigning that she has done and
uh when she revealed that she is now
having end of life care she opened a new
fund asking people to buy her a drink
and she's now raised more than three and
a half million pounds in just those few
days and i think will be a great
testament to her memory and reduce the
numbers of people suffering in the way
that she and her family have
and our final story is the news tonight
of the great reveal the platinum pudding
uh there's a lot on it let's just see
the picture of uh the finalists shall we
um there they are um presumably well
which which is the pudding
oh it's right
it's the one standing up at the back
that's a tall thing to be fair we think
okay we think it's that one this is
gemma melvin's lemon swiss roll and
amriti trifle which beat 5 000 desserts
and she said the inspiration for this
was um magran manan and the queen
herself who had lemon posit i understand
at her wedding selma tempted
uh not in the slightest and this is not
just because i don't like lemon desserts
but it's a lemon trifle with amaretti
and lemon swiss roll actually trifle
with amaretti biscuits and i i'm not
sure that i'm convinced by that but i'm
happy if somebody wants to offer me a
taste test
to find my view
i'm not sure it sounds fake it sounds
rather too complicated to make yes lemon
curd swiss roll sinclair's jelly lemon
custard emirati biscuits mandarin cooley
fresh whipped cream candied peeled
chocolate shards and crushed amerity
biscuits that's beyond me already i
don't know about you uh polly very
quickly
yeah i just think when you're chopping
up two different like manufactured
desserts lemon swiss roll and amaretti
biscuits you've somehow gone wrong it
doesn't quite feel like home baking to
me
kelly mckenzie salma shah lovely to have
with on